[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais de mama de la vida pas d'affaires clé supplémentaire
jusqu'à une loi en vigueur l'obscurité
Matt no D etre une voie de service
jean bébé salut dame
Alvin a dit oui je l'ai jamais entendu tu
veux chanter mes chansons mieux que les chansons de Tara
Elton aux moments déterminants de
la vie des gens et les chansons qui devraient
toutes provenir d'un lieu de caractère
[Musique] Les
Terriens chantent réellement dans  le film
et il est tellement convaincant et sa voix est
incroyable
Je doute qu'il y ait quelqu'un dans le monde qui
puisse douter que son Terrence se trompe juste
apporter la plus grande joie de ma
vie professionnelle faire ses films
qui ne dureront jamais
juste en profiter pendant que nous le pouvons
[Applaudissements]
vous